uh my next guest a political Outsider
burst onto the scene last year with a
plan to Splash uh and slash rather the
federal bureaucracy drained the swamp
now he's endorsed Donald Trump or
president joining us now with more
former 2024 presidential candidate
candidate VI ramaswami you know last
time you were on this show you got
pretty pissed off at me you still mad at
me or we we back being friends
again we buried that hatchet Sean and I
think it's a good thing in our movement
for us to be able to disagree
respectfully and have good debate and I
think that's what we had last time I
actually think I think you thrive on it
having watched you in this campaign I
think you thrive on it you live for it
you get energized by it I think that's
your personality um you got out of you
got out of the race after Iowa you've
now appeared on stage with Donald Trump
um and it was getting a little heated
between both of you also at the end of
that that campaign um you don't think
that that either Nikki Haley or Governor
D santis should stay in
why look at this point I think it was
fair to run this all the way through
Iowa but the people spoke loudly and
decisively and I do see an opportunity
here Sean I know a lot of people might
laugh at this idea but I see an
opportunity to reunite the country and
that starts with reuniting our
Republican party so running it through
Iowa was fair game I got about 8%
support I think I was about to get
something similar in New Hampshire I
think it was better to give Trump a
decisive Victory and I would ask for
everybody who was considering supporting
me in New Hampshire Libertarians
included to go in Trump's Direction end
this primary and then let's focus on
taking the America First agenda to the
next level and I think we're going to do
that best by actually first reuniting
our party then reuniting this country
and I do think that Donald Trump I'm
clearly this is why I endorsed him but I
do think he is the best choice left in
this I think it needs to be an America
first President I think the America
first movement reaches beyond the
traditional boundaries of the Republican
party so I'm focused on bringing the
Next Generation along with us for my
part Sean we had a lot of
people for direction we can bring them I
I think certainly after New Hampshire on
Tuesday certainly after South Carolina I
think there's a lot on the line for
Nikki Haley in in both those States uh
if if Donald Trump if the polls hold and
he wins New Hampshire and he's leading
by significant amount in South Carolina
I'm not sure what her path would be
towards the nomination the earlier the
Republicans unite I think the better I
don't like New Hampshire system uh with
an Open Primary where Democrats can
change their party affiliation up to
pretty much the last minute and then you
know wreak havoc in a Republican primary
that's been happening thousands of
Democrats have re-registered as either
Independents or as Republicans just so
they can vote in the Republican primary
that concerns me a little bit your
thoughts on
that well one thing is I think we should
stand against all forms of election
interference in the GOP Primary Shan so
whether that's Maine or Colorado one of
the things that I said was that I would
voluntarily have removed myself from the
ballots in Maine and Colorado if they
forcibly remove Trump I think the right
answer for both Haley and DeSantis would
have been to say the same thing anytime
there's outside election interference
from the other side in a GOP Primary I
think we should be United in standing
against it and the fact that we're not I
think represents a bit of a problem and
so for a lot of reasons I think after
New Hampshire I would say even before
New Hampshire the right step is for
Haley Dan sanis to drop out let's unite
behind Donald Trump and then make this
not just a Republican party's movement
make an America first movement that is
bigger than one man and bigger than one
party bringing the Next Generation along
with us and the earlier that starts this
year the better that is going to be for
our movement and our country and that's
where I stand the the agenda is simple
you control the borders we become energy
dominant not just independent but
dominant we we sell these resources then
we can cut taxes then we can start
paying down the $40 trillion in debt and
in terms of foreign policy I agree with
a lot of your points I don't want
Americans involved in Endless Wars uh I
feel Joe Biden has just botched the the
whole Ukraine effort uh by putting
handcuffs from the beginning on zalinski
I do want to see Israel win their war
against Terror because the Islamic
radical terrorists that attacked them on
October 7th want to attack us I think
the world has to at some point deal with
Iran and that's where I wanted to
specifically ask you what do you do with
the number one state sponsor of Terror
there wouldn't be hotti Rebels armed as
well as they are without the Iranians
the same with Hamas the same with
Hezbollah uh the same with a lot of
these groups a lot of this goes right to
the mullers in Iran should the World
Unite and make sure that they never get
nuclear weapons and should they take out
their refineries which is their ability
to make money to ferment
her so I'll say three things there Sean
first on the point on Israel Israel is
now proving it is able to get its job
done the number one thing we need to do
is provide the Diplomatic support that
allows them to get their job done
without having to actually be halfin
half out which I think is worse for
Israel and worse for the United States
and you have Biden now second guessing
their decisions they don't need a
backseat quarterback or an armchair
quarterback that's not what they need
and so as we now move to the houthis
what I would say is my rule of thumb
when it comes to foreign policy is if
you hit us whichever group it is that
hits us we hit you back 10 times harder
that has to be the rule it's what I
would tell my son if he's being bullied
in school it's the same principle in
human nature as in foreign policy if
somebody hits you hit that group back 10
times harder is it in the world's
interest and the US's interest to make
sure Iran never becomes nuclear equipped
absolutely and I think whether it's
Saudi Arabia or Iran we should make sure
that we stop nuclear proliferation in
the Middle East I do think it was a
mistake for the US to engage in
discussions about nuclear technology
transfer to Saudi Arabia last year
that's something that was underd
discussed but keeping nukes out of
Iran's hands absolutely a vital priority
where I am different than the Lindsey
Grahams or others in the Republican
party is I don't believe a preemptive
strike on Iran is a good idea to the
contrary I think we can deal with I
think a lot of these threats
diplomatically through smart use of our
economic fortitude become as you said
energy dominant again we need to become
a net exporter of energy which takes the
legs out of Leverage from our enemies on
the global stage that's the right focus
and so that's where
America I think is the Right Way Forward
there are reports that Iran could be
just a month two months three months
away from a nuclear weapon and and
marrying that to their radical ideology
and their fomenting of Terror um they
would be the people that would do it in
my view scary scenario let me ask you
this you supported president Trump yeah
the president has talked about you maybe
joining his administration if he's
elected uh any particular job that you
would
want so Sean the truth is I'm in this
for the country there's a lot of ways to
drive changing this country inside and
outside government for the last few
years I've been doing it through the
market I started strive to compete
direct directly against black rock and
State Street and Vanguard that's what I
was doing for the couple of years before
I ran for US president for the year
running into it and so I I'm all in for
the country and right now my focus is
making sure that we do elect Donald
Trump as the next president of the
United States it's not even about me
it's not about Trump it's not about one
man it's about this country so that's
what I'm most focused on and whatever it
is for the country I'm all in to do the
right thing well uh listen you got to
get a lot of credit you ran hard you
came out of nowhere uh you got a lot of
attention you made a lot of people mad
which was interesting to me um and I I
can sense that your passion is real I
don't I don't I don't think you can fake
that and it'll be interesting to see
what your future is in the world of
politics obviously you're very young
and I'm sure we'll be talking many times
in the future we appreciate you being
back thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else